lancaster california 70 miles north of
los angeles is home to casa roma the
oldest restaurant in the city how's your
pizza guys in spite of having absolutely
no restaurant experience nyla and her
son jeremy bought this failing landmark
restaurant with the hope of turning it
around two and a half years ago i was in
real estate i was sitting around looking
at business opportunities and i found
casaroma i talked my oldest son into
getting in with me and had we had known
the restaurant business very well we
probably wouldn't have done it we gotta
get this place turned
soon me and my mom thought we were
buying a restaurant with a bar attached
to it you guys want to sit in the dining
room are you gonna go to the bar okay
but really it just was a bar with a
restaurant attached to it
my bar does all my business it's like
two different countries our bar is
always packed and the restaurants it's
empty
[Music]
in food on a good night i'm making 175.
on a slow night i'm making nine dollars
i just asked you for me your [ __ ]
drama that's [ __ ] and you know it
we've had almost 20 chefs over the last
two and a half years but i've had drew
for a year and eric for almost six
months
eric's a huge reason why costume isn't
doing well not one table not one tables
have their food yet he likes getting the
food out a timely fashion
and his food is very bland it's dry
i don't i lost my appetite i'm gonna
need five chicken breasts
i'm good at this i'm good at it do i
make it look fancy or can i put pine
trees and stuff that's not what i do i
make the food taste good it's
presentable and it's like [ __ ] that's
pretty damn good
eric and i do not get along in the
kitchen because he doesn't produce very
well and he expects me to do everything
i need every [ __ ] one of my pants
right now we totally are enjoying our
native chef ramsay's help because
there's something that's got to be
turned around about this place because
it definitely is a nightmare
if i closed down i don't know what i
would do
i raised four boys
and uh ran a home my whole life
five years ago i got a divorce
and then i bought this place two and a
half years ago and it kind of took up
the
the time
i don't care about getting rich from
here i just
it would be nice to pay my bills you
know and have some some extra money at
the end of the month
[Music]
casa roma says 1958 this restaurant is
nearly 50 years old and by looking at
the sign it shows
time to find out what it looks like
inside
hi
how are you
oh hi nice to see you welcome nice to
meet you this is nyla i'm nyla good to
see you this is my son jeremy jeremy how
are you buddy nice to meet you nice to
see you now this is uh very cozy no
windows anywhere no no no
we have a restaurant over there
in terms of business i mean the bar is
obviously busy
always busy bar's always busy how is it
nice it's our restaurant we can't get
going
to save our life what restaurant were
you working in before you got here i
wasn't he wasn't i work in the grocery
store and he works with carpet cleaning
grocery store and carpet cleaning
i know
is that blood down there what is that
no no just dirt i'll just dirt and just
out of interest with no previous
rational experience anywhere why would
you open a restaurant if you never
worked in one because we're insane
[Music]
so um i think it's about time i had a
little taste yeah
where's the dining room right through
here right through there jesus that cop
is disgusting i was so excited whenever
chef ramsay walked in the door it was
like wow i can't even believe he's here
i thought well here we go he's gonna see
the nightmare i'm really living ah
jesus
[Music]
crusty bits of lime lemon
and bits of tissue
on my table
hello hello how are you i'm fella thank
you how are you good i'm ashley ashley
nice to meet you darling so nice to meet
you i'll just give you those they were
on the table and little bits of i think
lime back from 1958. nice just down the
side of the back of my chair sorry today
excuse me excellent you seat i feel like
i mean i i know i'm not exactly the
smallest but i feel like i'm just gonna
go through is that normal like that no
it's not no wonder
i may i'll fix it in a minute um
casaroma fine italian dinning i mean
oh
or is that just an italian spelling
no weird
anyway um i'll start off with the
stuffed mushrooms please stuffed
mushrooms the monte cristo i'll go for
that as well
yeah i'm hungry as you can see and
finally i'm dying to taste a pizza the
casa roma deluxe what size would you
like yeah let's go for medium medium
yeah thank you for dying
you already got it leave this damn
[ __ ] thing open
okay i got a big order
people say well he's a five star
michelin chef okay so he's got four
tires and a spare kiss my ass that means
nothing to me
the [ __ ] on the blindside is disgusting
oh my god
why are you hiding there
you're trying to see have they brought
any food to you yes i found some limes
and lemons dehydrated down the side of
my uh chair
and bits of um tissue left on the uh
table do you have a cleaner in here
yes we do chrystal is she blind
probably hey you're not doing nothing
right now i'm cleaning up or stuff give
me give me a glass of ice water please a
white ice water yeah nyla i have an ice
water please
way to go two she's standing right
there my gosh
it's um
zero for zero 15 minutes in
nothing
i'm starving we got some appetizers
coming right what appetizers coming
it's cooking
[ __ ] thing
that's what snapped
damn
we got to get rid of all these dirty
dishes
you're killing me
[Music]
spend more time cleaning up after his
ass with the [ __ ] match [ __ ] that's
better i'll prop a seat
just turn that one
first it's done no it's not turn it
why is that kissing so slow
[Music]
if somebody wants me i'm out back we're
past half hour mark now so hey
things are looking
[Music]
you got your appetizers in there nope
hey what about appetizers they're all
cooking
you want to start on those pizzas relax
take a chill
i might as well keep fit do something
can i know go for job got a bathroom
coming up
nothing wrong with working off for lunch
when you get it
do you have anything on that last order
ready
any anything on that last order ready or
close no we're putting everything up at
one time we're just waiting for the
sandwich of the pizza you want you got
one thing you want to start a lady if
yeah if you got one thing close lay it
out
okay
what the [ __ ] you want to do that but
okay
[Music]
okay
we got the app oh geez
okay great
there's nothing off then huh i was
nodding off
thank you and that's stuffed with crab
right lovely okay thank you you're
welcome
wow
fine mushrooms
[Music]
jesus
soggy
tasteless there's not even crab or any
form of flavor or texture or anything in
there but what worries more than
anything they're just full of water
[Music]
what is it
[Music]
how is everything um yeah pretty vile um
are they frozen the mushrooms um they
should be making them fresh ready yes
parker didn't work i told you
the um stuffed mushroom cookie
you could definitely tell that you taste
that it was frozen
and you didn't like those at all either
deluxe pizza what is that thing
what's that sandwich that's a ugly
sandwich
yeah no [ __ ]
i'm not worried about him let's see what
he's got if he wants to [ __ ] and moan
that's his drama
okay
here's a deluxe and then here's your
monte crisco thank
you that powdered sugar yes
on the sandwich yes
with fries
yes
is that popular no
jesus
is actually dripping
fat
ew
when chef ramsay squeezed the monte
crisco and all that oil came out
that really disgusted me that was very
disgusting
pizza
maybe the best
is for last
[Music]
jesus
unfortunately
the dough is raw
so thick
like wallpaper paste raw
oh my god
and that's why clearly there's nobody in
the restaurant because any people that
can eat this kind of [ __ ]
another one's in the bar
drunk
after a long wait in an empty restaurant
for some horrible food gordon gathers
the staff so you're the sous chef and
you're the head chef to discuss the
nightmare that is casaroma
lunch
absolutely embarrassing
the fried sandwich
what planet are you on when you put that
[ __ ] together
[Music]
casaroma celebrates its 50th year this
year
yeah i mean what a [ __ ] embarrassment
[Music]
eric you knew i was coming for lunch
today i didn't know when you're whose
you were i said which one is this the
cup they wouldn't tell me ashley you
never asked which one
and it shouldn't matter if it was him or
her it doesn't matter whatever
i came here today yeah to taste your
best like any chef would do
when they go into each other's
restaurants yeah i'm not here to [ __ ]
catch you off guard so cut the limp dick
excuses and give me some [ __ ] respect
for the restaurant alone it was a bad
[ __ ] day pal now you're pushing it
enough i get it we understand
a bad day yeah [ __ ] happens
you never had a bad day i do have bad
days all the time especially having one
today
just relax take a chill pill reload and
do it again
what the big problem is with you eric
you've accepted it
in your opinion only
what
what part of that don't you freaking
understand what do you mean freaking
understand yeah what part of that don't
you understand
in your opinion only i haven't accepted
it
yeah and i [ __ ] up stuff yeah i [ __ ]
sorry try and reload and redo it there's
nothing edible
[Music]
we're out of the way
why are you walking away eric
so i don't [ __ ] rip your head off
appalled by the food chef ramsay's
little chat with head chef eric didn't
exactly go over well lunch
absolutely embarrassing
what planet are you on when you put that
[ __ ] together
why are you walking away eric
so i don't [ __ ] rip your head off
i was in awe when eric talked to chef
ramsay like that he's coming here to
help us out
don't be rude to him you got two minutes
two minutes i've got a week
[Music]
i'm not gonna give you no excuses at all
all right
long days
haven't been feeling 100 but i'm here
anyway you do what you got to do you
work try to get these people better let
me reload and see what we can do again
okay
i think we got a [ __ ] cop flat-footed
but i get to reload one time i won't get
caught flat-footed again you bet your
ass on that
person that we're writing yep c-e-c
s-a-n
what that's right that isn't even how
you spell sicilian is anybody not a
speller or it might be celian sicilians
from sicily really because s-i-c-i-l-y
i don't think there'd be a y no it's i i
am it's the sale
there we go thank god you guys saw that
[Music]
uh do you work here or you're just
bypassing come around so we can say
hello
this is jimmy jimmy and what'd you do um
i'm the son of the honors center and so
what'd you do
a little bit of everything uh-huh just
try and help out
[Music]
you know
what's that in there cranberry juice
cranberry juice nice little vodka
vodka and cranberry yes yes i see you
drink and work at the same time no i
don't work
oh you're not working out here okay no
no no so what do you do then outside of
here what's your job what's your
favorite construction operating
machinery okay so no one's got any
cooking or rational experience no no ah
not at off
excellent
[Music]
hey guys how you doing your chair here
and i'll put you one on the end i'm
gonna have the chicken parmesan he's
gonna have the chicken nuggets and fries
hey i got calamari to start and then
kids chicken nuggets and with fries
excuse me
do you have any questions about the
water okay spaghetti operator still
camping
chicken farm
okay
[Music]
eric you want me saute man
[Music]
do you want me to saute
eric and i do not get along in the
kitchen because we don't really
communicate very well
do you prefer working on your own
just sometimes yeah i can tell why is
that she's not saying anything just just
doing what i got to do yeah
oh dear
oh
i'm sure steph measures you're welcome
you dig in
[Music]
is it cooked
[Music]
[Music]
eric this sausage isn't done
i ain't got time for this
[Music]
it looks like it's frozen i'm sorry
about that guys
working here is life for us it's what
pays our bills and
to know that the cook is keeping us from
making money it's hard on us what was
wrong with the calamari uh what happened
to the calamari just came back they said
that it tastes like it was frozen but is
this normal yes
oh you know what can you do
group i need one two three four five
chicken breasts through
eric doesn't ever really push to get it
done
he just keeps telling me oh it's okay i
got it everything's gonna be fine
but it's not did you get the lasagna
drew or no
damn it am i the only one that [ __ ]
works here
it's an hour into dinner service and
several appetizers are getting sent back
to the kitchen
and only one table has received its
entrees this is probably the worst
shrimp scampi that i've ever had in my
entire life let me take it back to the
chef and explain it to him thank you
thank you i appreciate it
okay guys listen worst shrimp scampi
they ever had and they said no flavor at
all you know what can you do i need some
water to me
when food comes back like that the
shrimps you never taste it
you know what can you do
[Music]
i've never seen two cooks so far apart
from each other up until now
i get frustrated but
try not to get angry at people
[Music]
you know everybody says i'm a
[ __ ] anyway
so why should i perpetuate the problem
that's not necessary but you need help
if you don't get help we're going to be
in the [ __ ] in the next 10 15 minutes
next is it really 8 30 already it's true
after two hours
what is this normal this is [ __ ]
normal
this
is incredible right through those doors
has to be for me
one of the worst restaurants i've ever
seen in my entire cooking career the
chef doesn't give a [ __ ] the owner's
completely clueless and not any form of
communication between the kitchen the
restaurant and management it's a [ __ ]
shambles
[Music]
boy wait on there actually
i'm still waiting on chicken piccata
with paneer marinara and individual kids
pepperoni pizza half order spaghetti
with meat sauce eggplant parmesan with
angel and meat chicken piccata angel
with marinara three chicken farms
and a veal parmesan
for just one table
i felt like crying because it was that
embarrassing for me eric yes sir yeah
can i have your undivided attention sure
nothing's happening we serve one table
of four one table of two the last three
tickets half the order's gone out half
is still on the board
you haven't got a clue what's going on
you're running around crazy what chance
have we got serving one two three four
five six seven eight tables you asked
for one more cracker did lunch time let
me go big boy let me go i want to do it
again we're spinning around and serving
[ __ ]
do me a favor close the [ __ ]
restaurant i can't stand any longer and
watch that embarrassment
[Music]
as of now we're not going to be serving
any more dinners tonight i need
the door [ __ ] closed forget it all
right we're done for the night
this is a joke guys
you're pissed off you're frustrated
forget it good night
what restaurant stops their business and
tells everybody that they have to leave
there's no excuse
[Music]
at a point in the service when more food
was being returned and sent out i need
the door [ __ ] clothes gordon shut
down the restaurant as of now we're not
going to be serving any more dinners
tonight and confronted the chefs about
the problems in the kitchen this is a
joke guys you're pissed off you're
frustrated forget it good night it's now
time for the cold hard facts with owner
nyla i don't even know where to start
with a chef that can't even cook
something basic
why are you employing a chef that's that
incompetent
darling he's not in the slightest bit
interest in [ __ ] making it work he
doesn't give a [ __ ] about his cooking
doesn't give a [ __ ] about you and he's
here for one thing and one thing only
money
and the only restaurant that [ __ ] guy
will ever get a job
is in a restaurant that doesn't have any
customers
have you got any chance of surviving
here get rid of him
what are you scared of talk to me
there's got to be something
i need to find another chef so drew
what's wrong with drew drew i think can
carry it off so get rid of it
okay
[ __ ] me
i'm [ __ ] believable
hey hey i'm sorry i know no no no no
just wait a minute just wait a minute
jeremy come here
i feel real bad
the whole thing is this this isn't the
first time you've let us down
i don't know i just can't do it i know
but i can't do it eric i gotta make you
guys get your paycheck every week jeremy
and i never take a dime out of it
i know but i mean
the whole thing is just not gonna work
because you okay so what do you want to
do
we're going to part ways okay okay
okay
damn it
i got [ __ ] on that deal
he couldn't pull off lunch couldn't pull
off dinner and so
we just had to let him go i can't you
know i can't do this
with head chef eric gone gordon is
hoping sous chef drew can rise to the
occasion that was a tough one tonight oh
they are very tough don't get down in
the dumps tonight with [ __ ] very much
clearly at its best
but
you don't need me telling you that
because that was embarrassing very much
yeah is that how you run it hell no good
tomorrow we go again sir thank you thank
you i need you all right yes thank you
good night tonight
i'm glad eric's not in our kitchen
anymore because maybe it'll give me an
opportunity to step up and do something
okay
that was embarrassing not only a bad
morning but a bad evening for every
plate we put out there this evening
we were losing what little reputation we
had left to salvage this place
what chance would we have getting all
those tickets out there was no chance to
put it bluntly that chef possibly the
worst chef in america today
the quicker you put a man like that out
his misery it's the biggest favor you've
done for him and the restaurant
okay tomorrow's a new day
i've got drew that's what i've got left
to work with what's his strengths uh i
would say pizzas calzones
um his lasagna is awesome right drew is
the only saving grace i've got there i'm
gonna work with him tomorrow i've gotta
be by his side tomorrow and start from
scratch okay
[Music]
good night thank you
i think drew will step up and i think if
he gets some confidence behind him i
think he can do it
the last 24 hours was one of the
toughest days ever spent in a restaurant
last night we did get rid of the chef
which was a positive move
now i need drew to step up to the mark
jeremy to support his mother more i got
here early this morning so i'm gonna
check out the place properly
with no interference
jesus
christ almighty where'd you start in a
place like this
roast beef
dating back when
[Music]
now what is that there
just me defrosting
again no sign of what it is
fresh palmer ham
is caked in mould
this is outrageous
look at it it sticks to your [ __ ]
hand
is that rancid
[Music]
[ __ ] you now
that's just
over three months old
jesus christ almighty
oh god
[Music]
after witnessing one of the worst
kitchen walk-ins he has ever seen gordon
moves on to an area outside the kitchen
that restaurants are judged upon the
bathroom one of the best ways to check
the hygiene of any restaurant is always
through his bathrooms
turn that on and turn the lights off
right
this could be quite scary
oh my good god
green and yellow
identifies bodily fluids
any form of bleach or any form of
cleaning will be identified through the
color blue but the body fluids on here
is extraordinary
[Music]
look as high as the ceiling oh my god
even the ceiling's caked in it oh my god
this is shocking
[Music]
wash your hands
yeah
honestly i've seen enough
let's get the [ __ ] out of here
[Music]
disappointed by the state of the
restaurant gordon is concerned about the
family's commitment to its own
restaurant right got in early this
morning
suck a new day and
i'm somewhat
[Music]
not just confused but disappointed yeah
come with me let me show you something
[Music]
how old is that
tuesday
tuesday oh come on guys
how old is this
but hold it and smell it
let's come outside the walk-in is just
rubbish really it looks like [ __ ] it's
horrible it's old
probably about as old as eric
this is the killer for me pass it round
it's three months old
and then look only in california
[Music]
what
in the [ __ ] is that
made me sick i hated to see it we talk
about cleaning out the refrigerator
making sure things are clean all the
time
and to my surprise they aren't nyla the
state of that fridge in there confirms
whoever's running this place in terms of
kitchen management has given up they
didn't give a [ __ ] about you and they
don't give a [ __ ] about standards
i went into the bathrooms
and that's where it got worse
i need two minutes with you
you start taking that out yeah
um hey get a bin and get every ounce of
dirt out of there
having a dirty refrigeration unit is one
thing
having a filthy bathroom is something
that [ __ ] scares the hell out of me
this thing here detects body fluids
just
have a look at this
that's body fluids up there that
there has got nothing to do with any
form of cleaning
look at the [ __ ] state of this
green green green green green
but here's where it gets really scary
how may i hold it up there it looks like
some of you may have peed on the ceiling
the walls the doors you know
could be throw up i can't even imagine
you know i mean it made me sick i didn't
even want to touch the door not coming
out myself bring your son in yeah i'm
not going in there
my god
this is body fluid
body fluids on the ceiling uh-huh
people are peeing up on the ceiling well
pretty good
as nyla shows her sons the bathrooms
gordon's inspection continues at the
kitchen prep area what in the [ __ ] is
going on here
it just shows that there's no bleach you
know these walls probably haven't been
washed oh you're hot
what in the [ __ ] are they look at that
there
holy [ __ ]
jimmy
come here people pissing on the ceiling
what
what is that
that's supposed to be his meatballs
good god
have a look those are from super bowl
sunday
super bowl sunday
what is that
that looks like raviolis
soaking in water
i need to start stepping up taking the
reins taking control
and
doing what i need to do
my big worry is this is not difficult to
spot
you could spend 10 minutes after every
night's service behind the bar
walking through the kitchen and turning
this place upside down and you don't
need to be a [ __ ] rocket scientist to
understand that this place
is in desperate need of support
before i go any further i want the
[ __ ] place cleaner
[Music]
[ __ ] me
after a full day of cleaning gordon
realizes that if there is any chance of
relaunching this restaurant he has to
turn his attention to chef drew right
now i want you and i to go and cook some
pizzas and i'd like jeremy nyla to taste
them i've got a little trick on my
sleeve
this is a secret
between you and i
okay i want to find out if they can
actually
tell the difference
between
a frozen pizza
to something freshly made that goes in
okay
array of ingredients fresh yeah vibrant
exciting let your imagination go wild
and create yeah the ultimate pizza okay
let's go
who's the chef of this place
i guess i am now that's right while drew
creates his own signature thick crust
pizza gordon is preparing a special thin
crust pizza that will be on casa roma's
new menu lovely
working with chef ramsay was like one of
the best things ever like oh my god i
just worked with a world-class chef
frozen pizza and yours
right ready huh nice
okay
so two nice pizzas i'm gonna be looking
for a verdict on both of you
[Music]
i mean i like this one mm-hmm good
jeremy take one as well yeah
i'm so glad you chose that one though
because this one here was frozen cheap
[ __ ] i was shocked when chef ramsay told
me that one pizza was frozen because i
thought it tasted a lot like our pizza
we had
the good news is both you know your
pizzas now let me get you my pizza this
is a thin crust
i like this too these two
are the type of pizzas that should be on
your menus we are going to relaunch this
restaurant and we are going to shout
from the rooftops how good these pizzas
are
i'm
[Music]
in order to transform casa roma gordon
and his team needed a full day to turn
this broken down italian restaurant into
a contemporary pizzeria
nice to see you guys how are you feeling
nervous nervous nervous now
just have a look at the new decor at the
outside of the newcastle roman
technology blindfolds
nice
nice new colors
the concrete jungle is gone yes the
italian flag
we've got the most amazing size casa
roma pizzeria but look at the windows it
felt like we're in prison before now
it's more inviting
are we ready to see the new interior
let's go
come through come through come through
come through
[Applause]
i was shocked beyond shocked it looks
like a bright new pizzeria that's the
crazy we got a nice new bright piece
area carpets have gone the booths have
gone chairs realigned new colors
and the restaurant's been painted from
top to bottom
no more hideous rugs no more carbon
clean just nice come through look huh
look at these new chairs the bar has
been sanded and stained twice throughout
the night and now we have a theme coming
through
we were trying to be fine dining and
then we had the bar and it was like two
different countries now it's all blended
together and we're one big pizzeria
everybody can come and have fun now this
place needs to celebrate its 50th year
with a comeback we are gonna hold the
first annual casa roma pizza eating
challenge yeah thank you
i love it
[Music]
in recent years the community's
perception of casa roma is as a bar with
an inferior italian restaurant attached
gordon knows this restaurant now has to
reintroduce itself as the new happening
pizzeria in town
thank you very much indeed welcome to
the first ever casaroma pizza eating
challenge
it was great to see that many people
supporting us today and actually getting
out and being part of the relaunch okay
contestants are we hungry yes are we
ready
five minutes
on your marts
eat
[Applause]
[Music]
come on guys take some water it goes
down a lot easier i can't do it come on
jimmy okay
jeremy is substituting for jimin
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Applause]
the pizza eating contest was definitely
a fun way of spreading the word that
casa roma has changed there's a new look
to it and there's a new menu give it up
please round the pools
[Music]
four hours prior to relaunch gordon goes
over the new dishes this is doable
uncomplicated nothing frozen and freshly
home baked pizza wow
chicken wings serve with a cherry pepper
sauce stuffed mushrooms a bit of a house
speciality
bruschetta simple look at it it's a lot
more condensed yeah it's cooked to order
it's fresh okay good get familiar with
the food have a little taste the menu is
easier it's lighter
it's more sufficient it's it should be
great oh good huh that's crazy
tonight
honestly for me is one of the most
important nights in 50 years we've got
to make a mark yes yes
absolutely tonight's tonight tonight is
definitely the night
[Music]
god bless casa roma let's go yes
[Music]
how are y'all doing tonight
thank you
drew
yo first order on most important let's
go i want to shine for chef ramsay today
and it would be silly not to because i
have the best opportunity ever that i've
ever had in my life to actually show
that i can handle it so we got our
setups for the mushrooms yeah wings and
garlic knot so we're ready good
hi guys how you doing are we ready to
order
for relaunch dinner drew has nyla's son
jimmy assisting with calzones and pizzas
put the dough on and stretch it all the
way out till it's even with that jimmy
had to be back here to be solid and pick
up the pace a little bit and he's never
done that before try not to make love to
it and you'll make it happen okay we're
working on the calzones right now please
the wings
you're welcome and i'll be right back
with the other two
now you're done
those aren't cooked so get get her back
here the whole evening started and
everybody was in a rush and all of a
sudden food was going out cold drew
they complained that these chickens are
bloody in the center they're not even
hot quick oh man i was rather
embarrassed when the chicken came back i
was like oh come on not we're not
starting like this you know
i gotta relax and not try to rush things
that take time
that is the second time she's brought
that back and that is
not recovered
[Music]
okay
it was extremely embarrassing chef
ramsey was completely disgusted as well
was i [ __ ] me same [ __ ] table there's
a second [ __ ] bowl look at me
they got to go in the pan and in the
oven not even hot in the center what's
going on not good
enough come on
once is a [ __ ] joke twice is just
disgusting
no rush i know i'm just trying to tell
everybody you know just keep working
i don't know what the hell that thing is
jimmy is it your first attempt at a
calzone ever and it's the worst one i've
ever seen but it's cooked
it was just the size of the [ __ ]
thing is that for two
it's a large the calzone was
huge you could probably feed about five
people with it jimmy yes the calzones
yeah are huge yeah be careful the size
oh look at all the cheese
i thought i had a large
usually i just got one of those you
could feed the station but i think it's
huge
cut down the sides like that yeah that
can fill an entire football end zone
look at the size of it yeah i want them
coming back for more yeah your other
ones are better
jesus christ i need some form of quality
to control guys yeah it's like a loaf of
[ __ ] bread in there most important
thing here is [ __ ] standard slow down
and pay attention to detail yeah
has this piece have been started you
just got up there on the window you want
to go ahead and take that order and
start looking at it it's coming because
he [ __ ] up and he had to make another
one it's a calzone he's getting beat up
over here take a deep breath stop
pushing me and just chill okay you're
making me hurry [ __ ] up i can't okay
have anything to [ __ ] do it go for it
[Music]
[ __ ]
this is unbelievable true now starting
to feel the pressure and it's showing
cracks are appearing he's fighting with
the owners fighting with the chefs and
he's not careful this place is going to
start sinking what a way to celebrate 50
years
hold on jan do not take that with orders
in the kitchen backed up don't tell me
okay sorry customers have a lot of time
on their hands
we got to pull it together we're like
this rag right here right now you know
we got to pull it together okay i need a
large deluxe calzone and a small deluxe
calzone the mushroom calzones fire i got
the calzona calzones in right yes okay
thank you in a dramatic turnaround head
chef drew has finally taken gordon's
advice by taking complete control of the
kitchen this is your mushroom calzone
and orders are moving out to the
customers promptly drew is doing a great
job he stepped up to the plate i'm real
proud of him
that looks pretty good
this one goes to the bar
right here thank you
so nice to actually see food coming out
fast it's pretty good huh i think this
new menu is a huge success because it's
just easier
bye guys
it was so good yes i know and we're
taking it home
that it guys
i pulled it off
thank god for ramsey
okay good
well done
[Music]
after a most impressive turnaround
gordon has some final words for the
staff
i know i put a fork and a spoon on the
wall yeah but you didn't have to make
the [ __ ] calzone to match it
holy crap
what was that for a ten time yeah cut
them down we're here to make money not
give it away
yeah good
now you've tasted it make it work
we will oh yeah we're going to keep each
other motivated on us
consider we have a new menu new chef new
look if we couldn't make this restaurant
work we'd definitely be idiots trust me
if everyone does their bits
three months down the line this place is
going to be rocking my heart's here he
saw that he saw that it's a dream of
mine
i just wanna i wanna make it live
what a week when i first arrived that
had to be the worst ever italian
restaurant going
then we made some drastic changes
promoted the chef reinvigorated the
owners and turned this place into a
really nice classy pizzeria only hope
now lancaster embraces it but one
thing's for sure that has to be the
biggest [ __ ] calzone i've ever seen
in my entire life
holy mackerel
you